there's a lot that looks familiar in the
fourth matrix movie but this time neo
has no idea how much things have changed
if you were blinded by nostalgia you may
have missed these small details in the
matrix resurrections
deja vu is usually a glitch in the
matrix
during the montage of tom anderson's
day-to-day life we see him eating
noodles at a restaurant several times in
a small nod to the series past the
location directly parallels a line from
the first movie and provides a maybe
subliminal clue to the audience that neo
has indeed gotten plugged back into the
matrix after neo is sent back into the
matrix for the first time he's driven
down a familiar street with morpheus and
trinity at one point he points out the
car window and identifies a restaurant
he used to lie he then spends some time
pondering how this never actually
happened and how his memories aren't
real good
what
i used to eat that
good noodles fast forward 22 real life
years later and who knows how many in
universe years and neo is back in a
simulation again and dropping hints
about it by eating those really good
noodles
after meeting up with bugs and the new
morpheus neo is informed that he sees
himself differently than everyone else
literally he's put in front of a mirror
and shown that due to technological
shenanigans most people see him as an
old man with white hair and a white
beard this part is pretty shocking
provided of course you missed the fact
that we saw it already if you want the
truth near
you're going to have to follow me we are
definitely given at least one somewhat
obvious hint when bugs recalls seeing a
man who looked nothing like neo but was
clearly neo we're also given a much less
obvious hint one that requires a keen
attention to detail pay attention to
scenes when tom anderson is in his
bathroom especially when he's not
looking at the mirror the time everyone
else sees the gray haggard man is shown
in the reflection it's brief but it's
there and it's a neat clue for either
observant viewers or those doing a
re-watch where are we
one of the first big revelations in the
matrix resurrections is that the
machines never returned neo's body to
humanity after he sacrificed himself
it's certainly an intriguing plot point
but one nobody would bat an eye at
unless they were familiar with the
matrix online a massively multiplayer
online game active in the late odds the
game was meant as a follow-up to the
original trilogy with the wachowskis not
particularly intent on making a fourth
movie at the time in a 2005 interview
with ign the wachowski said that they
wanted an mmo because like their movies
it required people to be active
participants rather than passive
observers those are the people the
people who thought about it who worked
at it who we ultimately made the trilogy
for and it now makes perfect sense to us
that they should inherit the storyline
sounds like proof that this was
canonical right
nope ben chamberlain the last full-time
developer to work on the matrix online
told eurogamer in 2021 i don't think we
ever worried about whether our game was
canon i don't think anyone who worked on
it ever thought that anything we were
doing would be regarded as canonical in
the same way that the movies were this
is just a way of saying that the game is
not canon despite massive speculation
the game infamously saw the
assassination of morpheus but in
resurrections we find out that morpheus
instead lived on as a leader of humanity
and died of other causes leaving a much
older niobe to take his place but
there's one detail that carried over
from the matrix online and it's the
inciting incident of the game neo's body
was never returned by the machines and
interested parties want it back it's
hard to imagine that lana wachowski
didn't have that in mind nothing
comforts anxiety like
little nostalgia the first matrix movie
introduces the dangers of deja vu via a
black cat what did you just say after
neo sees the same cat twice he's
informed that deja vu is a sign of a
glitch in the matrix an indicator that
something's wrong it's hard not to get a
sense of deja vu in the fourth movie
which is by design after all
resurrections is both textually and
subtextually about making another matrix
movie as such there's at least one overt
reference to this the analyst's black
cat named deja vu who tom anderson does
not like but there's one more instance
of deja vu that's easy to miss unless
you're paying close attention during the
montage showing tom's day-to-day life we
see a cluster of birds flying through
the sky multiple times they fly forward
before swooping backwards what's easy to
miss is that the exact same birds fly in
the exact same loop outside the exact
same window they're a glitch it's not a
coincidence they show up around the same
time as bugs and morpheus and it's
certainly not a coincidence that we
watch a similar group of birds dissolve
mid-swoop towards the end of the movie
i remember this it was obvious from the
beginning that the analyst was keeping
neo placated as tom anderson after all
he was and perhaps the least subtle part
of resurrections the one prescribing the
blue pills there's also another striking
detail about him the blue frames of his
glasses we don't find out that the
analyst is the one behind the new matrix
until most of the way through
resurrections at which point he removes
his glasses for most of the rest of the
movie his glasses act as his personal
blue pill in a way he gets to see the
artificial world he built when he needs
to get aggressive he removes his glasses
as if to demonstrate that he's not
hiding anymore we do see him wearing the
blue glasses one more time at the very
end after neo and trinity break into his
residence and reveal that they've taken
over the matrix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]